Kourtney Kardashian says she'd be okay
if the Keeping Up cameras went away as
brother Rob reportedly skips out on
filming his new show with fiance blac
Chyna Court opens up in the new issue of
au magazine saying she too loved some
anonymity quote I don't want the show to
end but I sometimes think I would be so
happy if it did and I could just move
away from it all the mom of three adds
that by the end of every season she's
had enough but then always decides to
come back for more
now the question is is a robber ready
for more the 29 year old only recently
signed on for a spinoff with his wife to
be but reports have popped up that he
doesn't want to film it anymore a source
close to rob says that's not exactly
true telling ET he is still filming
quote he is just going through one of
his mood swings which is common for him
power source adds that this is quote
nothing new and that Rob just goes
through dark periods sometimes quote he
gets depressed and doesn't want to
really do anything doesn't leave the
house it got better for a bit when he
first started dating her but he's in a
rut now he'll snap out of it